Corgi land read it if I sweat a lot do I
pee less
yes your urine becomes more concentrated
because you have less fluid to eliminate
so that's why when you sweat you should
always be drinking more water to make up
for the losses that occur when you sweat
also remember when you have a fever you
also lose fluids more rapidly and as a
result you should be drinking more
fluids what would happen if all your
bones suddenly teleported out of you you
become a bag
you just be a bag and the handle would
be like your mouth because teeth are not
bones so you could still grab by the
teeth and the teeth are like the handle
clearly I've watched one too many horror
movies is it possible to get food PTSD I
had to take a cinnamon apple flavored
medicine for a flu two months ago I
don't know what medicine that is and I'm
pretty sure it didn't do anything sorry
to say a lot of over-the-counter
medications are unnecessary for flu and
it made me throw up clearly didn't do
well for you either ever since if I
smell or see something cinnamon flavored
I feel nauseous for the rest of the day
I wouldn't necessarily call this PTSD
medically speaking but colloquially
speaking meaning just like an average
words I understand what you mean by PTSD
because it's an experience that is
bringing back a memory but it's really
more of your olfactory region of your
brain being very intimately tied to the
memory portion of your brain and as a
result that nasal smell that you
experience transmits to the memory makes
you remember how you feel is it
unhealthy to eat your boogers or does it
help boost your immune Unity I would say
it is unnecessary and I would say it's
unhealthy because odds are if you're
eating your boogers you're probably
doing it with dirty fingers and your
digits are potentially the dirtiest
highest bacteria count portion of your
body so don't eat your boogers is it
possible I just became lactose
intolerant later in life I was drinking
a frappe and then I had intense
abdominal pain and an urge to use the
bathroom and it's happened every time I
drink milk since this has never happened
before
um Not Unusual to develop or lose
allergies and intolerances throughout
your life sometimes they can even be
temporary due to some sort of illness
sometimes viral related don't know if
that's exactly what's happening to you
but definitely worthwhile to talk to a
doctor about it I really want to start
exercising more but I find going to the
gym or running so boring is there a more
fun exercise you'd recommend yes first
of all try all those exercises that you
found boring with a friend that goes a
long way try taking a boxing class where
they teach you techniques and you're
punching the bag and you're learning how
to move around with the bag try rock
climbing try bouldering try stepping
outside of your comfort zone and taking
a dance class any type of movement that
makes your heart rate go up is
considered exercise so have fun with it
Andrea from YouTube I'm on a long wait
list to be seen by a new therapist is
there any self-help things I can do in
the meantime okay journaling very
beneficial three good things at night
very beneficial like literally writing
three good things for a period of two
weeks can help reshape your mind into
how you're thinking about your anxieties
and the good things that happen that we
oftentimes Overlook as a survival
mechanism that our brain does but the
best thing to do is something that I
recommend to all patients called
bibliotherapy read a book called feeling
good or feeling great by Dr David Burns
and do some of the exercises in those
books I think it's a great way to start
if obviously it ever becomes too the
symptoms become so severe that you feel
like you're losing control that's a
9-1-1 call but otherwise I think
bibliotherapy for mild symptoms is a
great place to start Gab Evan H from
YouTube if I drink a glass of water how
long will it take until I pee it out
what about food if I eat a big meal how
long does it take to come out does any
of it come out in different times
there's a lot of variability here
because if you consume water and you're
already well hydrated so it's like
excess water it'll come out faster if
you consume water and then a
caffeine-based substance like tea or
coffee that acts as a diuretic it will
also come out faster food so many
variabilities is there fiber in the food
how much did you eat beforehand at what
time of the day did you eat how healthy
is your digestive system for example my
patients that have diabetes can develop
something known as diabetes related
gastroparesis the natural waves called
peristalsis that keep the food moving in
your gut actually get sort of thrown out
of whack and as a result therefore food
doesn't move as well throughout your gut
so you feel bloated you develop nausea
vomiting so as you can see Gavin a lot
of variability here so I don't want to
give you a Surefire answer chassis red
YouTube my mom always told me the best
way to get rid of hiccups is for someone
to scare you she's right I actually
don't think that's a good way and
remember there's actually nerves
involved when it comes to hiccups
because that's happening as a result of
a diaphragmatic spasm the diaphragm is
that giant muscle that sits below the
lungs that pulls the lungs down to
breathe and then pushes up and relaxes
and then helps the lungs uh exhale so in
this scenario you have the vagus nerve
interacting with the phrenic nerve
creating this diaphragmatic spasm and
what I found to work best for me and so
many of my patients is a little spoon of
granulated sugar there's also some
really good evidence-based methods for
breathing into a paper bag to increase
carbon dioxide levels or like taking a
breath in holding taking another quick
deep breath in without exhaling and then
another time one more time there's
actually a prescription medicine called
Thorazine that you can use to control
hiccups when they're gone on for days on
days on days and you can't control them
with the natural methods that we just
discussed but we really Reserve those
for complex cases and they do happen
with certain chemotherapy agents and
surgical situations that I've seen in my
patient in the past is a stinky belly
button a healthy belly button
I'm gonna go ahead and venture to say
with the exception of your excrement AKA
vomit poop nothing should really smell
bad on your body your nose is acting as
a chemical receptor to tell you that
there's something off so for example if
your belly button starts creating a foul
smell odds are there's some kind of
bacteria and or fungus having a little
nightclub party in there with DJ
the thing you pull out of your belly
button called
BJ Lynn spinning
lent this skit Cloud enthusiasts Reddit
okay but like how do doctors learn CPR
do you have to go to a normal CPR class
like normal people is there Just One Day
in med school where they teach you is
there a whole semester-long course
called CPR 101 that would be epic I
would go to a chest compressions
year-long course you do something called
BLS and while pretty much anyone can go
to this as long as you sign up most
medical schools have a day where all the
students are scheduled to go through
this and then usually what we also do as
Physicians is called ACLS training which
is the next step after BLS because
that's basic life support what to do if
the Heart full on stops and you need to
intervene you need to give medications
if the heart is being so fast or so slow
how to intervene things to check this is
my BLS provider card here that you get
when you complete the course my ACLS
provider card look at that American
Heart Association did you see my kiosk
if you haven't check it out if someone
goes through a horrible accident loses a
limb well that limb goes stiff from from
rigor mortis or does that only happen to
the whole body
oh that's a good question I have no idea
I have not experienced enough traumas in
my medical education to know if that's
true Mosh Pit YouTube why don't we ever
sneeze while we're asleep why does it
only happen when we're awake uh it
probably can happen to some who are in
light sleep but in deep Sleep these
types of reflexes are probably suspended
and I I still think that if there's
enough stimulation of the airway you
probably could sneeze out of asleep but
you're awake at that point so you're not
asleep tricky tricky questions like what
came first the chicken or the egg the
sneeze or the Sleep hey Dr Mike do I
need to eat the actual fruits and
vegetables or can I just take the
vitamins that have the same ingredients
that way I don't have to waste calories
on the veggies no eat the veggies What
vitamin supplements are are the things
that we've so far learned that is the
healthy part of fruits and vegetables it
doesn't mean that's the only part
there's so many other things within
fruits and vegetables like
phytonutrients that we don't fully yet
understand or have fully yet explored
and also there's other benefits to
eating fruits and vegetables outside of
the mineral and vitamin content like
fiber which supplements don't contain
I've had a hernia so I've assumed for a
number of years it only hurts when I
press on it is there any reason I should
go to the doctor to treat this or can I
just go on doing about not doing
anything about it for another decade I'm
going to talk about an inguinal hernia
now because there are other types of
hernias and they all carry different
risks but if we're talking about an
abdominal hernia or abdominal wall
hernia what ends up happening is you
create a risk for something known as
bowel incarceration your intestines AKA
your gut actually can poke through this
hole because a hernia is an opening in
the abdominal wall and if you have an
opening and a piece of the intestine
sticks out of that wall and then it
starts getting choked out because of its
positioning when I say choked out means
the pressure around it due to
inflammation or its position starts
increasing so much pressure that it cuts
off circulation and starts strangulating
that bowel that's a surgical emergency
because that bowel is literally dying
and needs to be rescued so the reason
why we proactively operate on hernias is
to decrease the likelihood of that
happening and what's interesting about
hernias is that the larger the hole
meaning the bigger the hernia the less
likelihood that uh an incarceration or
strangulation of the bowel would
actually happen so it's the smaller ones
that don't look as bad that actually
tend to be more problematic when I've
got a cold and I'm blowing my nose a lot
my snot changes color sometimes it's
clear sometimes it's yellow what's the
difference it's about the cells that are
present inside your snot a lot of people
make the assumption that if there's not
as a certain color they know whether or
not it's a bacterial or viral infection
that's not always true because for
example many people say if you're not as
green that means you have a bacterial
infection that is true in some cases but
at the same time sometimes your snot can
start being clear and then towards the
end of your viral illness change color
to something that's yellow or green and
still be viral and not be bacterial so I
don't use that as the sole judge of
what's going going on it needs to be
thought about in a whole spectrum of
whether you're having bacteria-like
symptoms uh like fever sinus tenderness
and then the color of the snot can be
one of those variables but I wouldn't
use it as the sole discriminatory point
for making a diagnosis why does Vicks
Vapor Rub make I love that you said
Vapor Rub Vapor Rub uh I only gotta be
in geography people rub my girlfriend
just um just tell me people rub by the
way the podcast with Stephen he is a
banger and if you haven't signed up and
subscribe to the checkout podcast you're
missing out check it out because
everyone's loving it why does Vicks
Vapor Rub make my cough go away faster
than cough medicine what is that stuff
I'm pretty sure Vicks Vapor Rub is just
Menthol Menthol is interesting because
what it can do is create a cooling
sensation which feels good maybe create
some opening and dilation of the airway
on a superficial level but in reality
cough medicine doesn't really work I
really don't use cough medicine in the
huge majority of my patients unless I'm
treating the source of the cough like
acid reflux post nasal drip asthma where
I can give them an inhaler to
bronchodilate the spasm away I like
using it uh
a Steam Inhaler for when I have a coffee
it really feels like it opens things up
why is it so much harder to fall asleep
as an adult than it is a kid we have a
higher sleep need as children meaning we
sleep for longer hours and as we get
older the need for deep sleep decreases
the amount of sleep a one-year-old needs
versus 101 year old needs is drastically
different and something to also think
about that the number of REM hours of
sleep is difficult to maintain the older
we get and I'm sure anxiety has a
component there too but that's not one
that's routinely taught to us Connie
Thai how do I unclog my nostrils before
bed it always feels like one of them is
totally stuffed if I have a patient who
knows this stuffy quite often I would
try my best to narrow down to the most
common diagnosis and try some
medications like nasal sprays I like
using nasal saline to clear out the
nasal passageways because it's a benign
thing to do doesn't have real big side
effects and then there's other things
that we can do like histamine nasal
sprays steroidal nasal sprays and if
those don't work I really like to get an
uh ear nose and throat specialist on
board to do a fiber optic exam where
they put a little camera in to check the
anatomy there's different parts of the
nasal passageways that can be operated
on where I've seen patients get good
results and then some patients that have
overdone it so make sure that when you
do meet with an ENT talk about the risks
and benefits for your specific condition
also another cool tip here is throw a
humidifier in your room sometimes just
moistening the mucous membranes helps a
lot and also staying well hydrated thins
out mucus makes it easier to breathe as
well they say humans use only 10 of
their brains the smarter people use more
of their brains I think this is a
complete myth like I don't even have
evidence to say it but I think I've
looked this up in the past I think it's
a complete myth is there a health
benefit to wearing those barefoot shoes
with the toes in some instances there
might be but they're also significant
risks we've seen people develop stress
fractures because they have very thin
padding but then some people develop
stronger shins they have pros and cons
weigh them for your own individual
decision I've never really seen an
instance where I'm like yeah that was
the way to go I think if you're
interested in Barefoot training doing it
on Sand is probably the way to go but
doing it on hard concrete is just going
to create so much shock that will go
into your knees and hips that long term
I don't find it really beneficial is
marching band a sport does it raise your
blood pressure your pulse does it make
you sweat is it competitive if you
answered yes to those questions
definitely a sport
I want more questions leave them down
below and by the way never drink hot
stuff at this specific temperature that
I say in this video really important to
check it out like can prevent cancer by
watching this video and as always stay
happy and healthy
[Applause]
[Music]